we're only hearing about it cuz it's cat
you know how many times these
[__] stole from nobody's I
don't care if he AR on everybody I don't
care how messy it gets I don't give a
about none of that stuff these people
are thieves and a lot of people are more
protect think it's more important to
protect the image of black people rather
than rooting out evil people within the
community y okay people who steal and
piler they want to make sure we look
good meanwhile there's dirty happening
in the back Cat Williams interview so
essentially Cat Williams was on Shannon
Sharp's podcast which is called the
Club sh and during the interview he
essentially aired out a bunch of people
in the industry everyone from the Kings
of Comedy SRI the Entertainer Steve
Harvey Kevin har for all kinds of
different reasons uh some for stealing
jokes others for claiming accolades that
they never had and the interview went
viral so some people had some things to
say a lot of the people who were named
had some responses on the whole stealing
jokes allegation a lot of people are
really shocked to hear that Steve Harve
sric the Entertainer stole jokes I can
tell you they absolutely did you can
watch the videos themselves um yeah I
mean they stole those jokes the same
Steve that went to go watch Mark Curry
do his whole sitcom and then stole
everything Mark Curry had Halloween was
a trip Halloween we couldn't afford no
Halloween costumes hey kids please mama
sent us down to the liquor store put
boxes on
us we didn't know what we were I don't
know what we
are
I don't know she didn't tell
her I think we UPS I guess I don't know
you've heard me say that every Halloween
I had the same outfit on every year I
just had a brown box it wasn't nothing
sad just and I asked my father could I
have a new outfit and he said no just
wear the same one it was just a brown
box and he just told me to tell
everybody I was the UPS man Cedric
doesn't write I'm sorry he doesn't write
gas is entirely too high that's all I'm
saying you are not supposed to be at the
gas station making life
decisions you just at the pump just
negro did I eat today I can't get no
half a tank I got six cigarettes I can't
even do it used to be if you had 10 $15
you could go to the gas station with
confidence cuz you knew you was either
going to be full or damn near full if
you had a 20 you ain't even talk to the
person at the counter you just 20 on 11
[__] used to be if you put $15 in your
tank you had time to bond with your
vehicle you had time to put the nozzle
in and set the clicker and look through
your car and clean off the dashboard and
look through your CDs and run in the
store and get some Pringles and a
snapper and it'll still be pumping now
if you put $15 in you can't even turn
around sound good for that son of a
[__] click you had your car radio up so
loud that you couldn't hear the damn
thing when it cut
off it look like this you flossing in a
SI Shi
[Music]
[Applause]
convertible
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh
they going to move to the
Moon ain't going to happen y'all move to
the Moon damn it we coming to the Moon
oh we'll be right behind y'all in space
shuttles with Cadillac
Grills n just rolling one head light out
tags be all
wrong all
Bas y'all know we'll drive a space
shuttle too that's right up our damn
alley a space shuttle is long they ain't
scared no black folk we a drive a space
shut we grew up driving long cars we a
drive a space shutter like it's a 72
dece in a
quarter we we get us a cigarette we get
us we be in a space shut like it's a 72
dude those jokes they both stole those
jokes some people like how do you know
um listen joke stealing is interesting
because some people don't feel like it's
a big deal and yet if one artist stole a
song from another artist you would think
it's always right for the artist to
pursue them in court but I can't call
somebody out for stealing my work if you
don't know the process of making a joke
especially when it's your and and they
didn't steal any joke cour to cast on
words this is one of his best jokes one
of the jokes he closed with and you
close on your best joke cuz you want
people to leave the show on the highest
note that's what they stole making that
joke is a lengthy process that can
sometimes take years mhm and you take an
idea you go about you perform it it
bombs it doesn't work well it's clunky
as [__] but you got to live through
those awkward moments with those
audience until you get to the point
where it's it's finalized product so you
go through all the ups and downs you
have other comedians watching you
improve like I know and memorize the
acts of most of the ICS I know cuz I see
them so often and I see the progress so
you get happy watching them improve and
you get to talk with them backstage and
sometimes they offer you little tip bits
you're like yo you missed that well last
time you performed it differently so you
go through that whole Ops and down and
then you get to the point where it's
ready for you to tour and do that stuff
and now you're proud because it's
killing in front of crowds and they're
loving it right in that one hour that
you spent with the crowd that one five
minutes that everyone's losing it on
right you spent years crafting and then
someone comes along sees your [__] and
then think they just because they they
they they tile with it a little bit or
change the premise enough that they can
get away with stealing it of course it's
going to burn you up cuz you strive for
that and now they taking the credit like
it's their own tribulations when it's
not that'll irk anybody that's why an
artist who seems their Melodies being
stolen has recourse in courts courts and
that's why people who have jokes stolen
want that same kind of recourse now does
this mean that Cedric the Entertainer
and Steve Harvey aren't great
entertainers no that's not what that
means some people are great performers
yeah they're just good at performing
other people's
bits all right and they're not the first
they're not the last and also keep it a
stack with you people from that era
stole a lot of jokes them old [__] was
constantly seeing jokes and you know
what the worst part is we're only
hearing about it CU it's cat you know
how many times these [__] stole
from nobodies you know cuz some people
just come up with one or two bits that
are really great and the rest they act
as trash but it's still theirs right
just cuz you're a one hit wonder does
not mean anyone has the rights to your
song and anybody who steals jokes like
this I promise you they steal from a lot
more people it doesn't just happen once
to be able bold enough to steal from a
famous person like C cuz that [__] was
being performed on television when they
stole from him they stole from a lot
more people and you can find it there's
all kinds of pores on forums people
doing side by sides of Steve Harvey with
other people he might have stolen from
and those bits sound crazy similar that
I could answer that question is by
telling the bomin story it's a true
story see there was this white family
they lived in Mississippi and they had
this man who worked for them
occasionally named binici and he did
various small jobs for them on and off
about a week one night he had just
finished bartending a party and the lady
of the house realized that she didn't
have any money so she said to him bomin
I I want to write you a check but I I
don't know how to spell
bomin and he said well I've been meaning
to talk to you about that see when I
came to work for you I told you my name
and then I said but you can call me by
my initials everybody around here call
me bomin is fine you call me that don't
even worry about it everybody call me
bomin I'm like all right so all week
long my ass talking about bomin what up
boy hey bomin run to the store grab some
Bill come on back my cousin say what you
calling
him bum
this he said everybody call him bomin
it's all right for me to call him that
like no man it a't
CJ he saying you could call me by my
initials that's what he's saying now
here's the thing not it's not because
two jokes sound similar that's
inherently stealing everything is
contextual okay well are you guys
running in the same circles okay how
similar has it been okay is it just
topical
meaning when the juicy smle stuff
happened a lot of people ended up
writing the same jokes people who never
met each other on different continents
how did that happen because enough
people looking at the same problem
enough people are going to come up with
the same ideas when it comes to the
solutions and things like that same
thing for jokes when a lot of people are
covering the same topic but then you
have to look at okay well how similar
are they and if you look at a cat's bit
it's a very physical bit he's doing
motions he's doing physical stuff when
you're replicating a lot of the same
physical gestures then I'm starting to
look at you like okay when you're using
a lot of the exact same words then I'm
looking at you like okay you've seen
that bit before I think we UPS I guess I
don't know and he just told me to tell
everybody I was a UPS man as a matter of
fact it kind of happened to you but it
was not stealing I remember that you did
a joke about we made a video about
abortion and we made a we we made a
video about abortion like we had like
30,000 subscribers on this channel we
made a video about and how you were you
you asked the question you're like I
just want to ask a question and you
said if it's her body her choice
shouldn't it be my money my money we
filmed that we cackle about it we post
that video the video goes out couple of
weeks after that Dave Chappelle special
come out and yeah yeah he had the same
someone dm'd me someone DM me like yo
Dave saw your joke I'm like
it's it's impos and and I'm going to
tell you that because of the to create a
special the jokes that you have on a on
that special the time frame that it
takes for you to build that joke for it
to be ready for that special two months
after you release that video it's crazy
it's it's that no that did not happen
but the similarity is possible and that
was for one line [__] the whole
bit no he stole that [__] he that [__]
from Mike Curry that that's 100% death
and and like I know the difference like
when I'm in Montreal and some other
random comics in Los anges is doing a
similar bit I've never published myself
online and we have the same bit I'm not
going to think he stoen right but when
you're a famous person like C you run
the exact same circles as these dudes
they see each other in clubs they watch
each other on television they stealing
each other's [__] yes you can't get away
with that kind of stuff that's crazy and
if here's the thing forget television
before Steve even puts that [__] up
online he has to be performing that [__]
in club somebody would have told him yo
that's cat's spit there's no way you get
away with that running that through a
bunch of comedy clubs without him
finding out there's just no way so do I
think these people absolutely and also
here's another thing once you get to
that kind of level of Fame all right
these cats they don't write their own
jokes they don't even really do stand up
like that people think because they were
great in their young years now they
doing all these movies they still great
no they got writers they got people who
handle this stuff for them that's how
Kevin Hart got nabbed one time is
because he has people who write for him
the promise where are these guys getting
their jokes from well they go in to Club
sometimes and they just pilling from
people
yep that's that's facts that's facts and
why a lot of these big names don't like
talking about it is because they don't
want to cause conflict because it
affects TV deals it affects brand deals
it's negative publicity but a lot of
this stuff happens all the time internet
internet business has got a lot of weird
and Shady people with weird practices
and because of personal relationships a
lot of people don't like saying nothing
so even big comedians who know this to
be true will not say stuff CU they don't
want to anger Kevin har or align
themselves with k or whatever it is but
these things happen all the time all the
time as a matter of fact that's why when
I went to Bobby Lee's podcast and I went
and I told him so why didn't want to say
nothing about Carlos Mania stealing your
joke and he's like well I said something
when he came to my podcast he okay but
I'm not talking about when they did that
little video and Joe Rogan was doing
that video and everything and stuff you
didn't you didn't they don't want to
talk they don't really want to do all of
that it's not everybody that really
wants to have conversation like that and
do stuff like that they didn't want you
know but I had to ask him I had the
opportunity so I did mind you it like I
said it's possible that people are going
to have the same similarity in the bits
like that if someone ever comes to me
and it has happen yo the bits is similar
to that I'm dropping that [__] I got
other jokes I don't want to even sound
like someone or remotely I don't want
even want to have someone being like
close or me making them remind them I
don't want to remind someone else of
another comedian if if it's even close
I'm like I I don't mind sometimes
because like I have a whole bit that I
wrote about sleep after you like s years
ago okay and then Joy Koy came out with
a special recently and it's there's some
similarities yeah you know someone
pointed it out to me and I'm like no cuz
I want I have videos of me doing it
seven years ago so I'm not getting rid
of it cuz I know I did it before him but
two it's like this is personal to my
life it's real MH so I don't need to let
it go but I understand the sentiment I
understand sentiment I'm not mad at you
for that yeah everyone got to make their
choice what is clear to me one they
stole it but of course it's going to be
it's going to be like a context of
course you know if I'm like but there's
one punch line there's one punch line
that I'm like that's crazy how yeah I
like that the rest of it is fine but
there's one that I remember watching his
I'm like I got I got I I'm just like
that's why I don't watch Comics I don't
watch Comics I understand I don't watch
anything but I'm like you know what cuz
I don't even want it to like cuz here's
something sometimes you accidentally
steal you hear it once you coming out
talking and then you get this funny idea
and not realize you'd already observed
it through osmosis a while back you were
you you heard some [__] 10 years ago and
then you iniz that I don't watch it
people like yo you see I I haven't
watched this special in like 5 years 5
years other than the comedians that I
watch locally I don't watch nothing
maybe that's not the best way to improve
I don't care for me this is what's
working
but moving past that so they stole it
okay I don't want any they stole it some
people don't like the idea that people
are fighting arguing about this uh they
don't like the cat exposed a lot of
these people people don't like the idea
it brings another problem because people
don't like the idea that a black man is
exposing another black man you know
there's that thing in the community
where you can't expose out loud your
community because it makes you look bad
in front of white people or in front of
the large majority of the people in
power and stuff like that and
automatically when you do so publicly
you are viewed as bitter as jealous as
angry but people don't ask the questions
of what's going on or they don't assess
of maybe what if there's something there
you know so there's also that there's
also that that that side of the story
where you can't talk about your own in
public there has to be that that sort of
uh fraternity Brotherhood that has to be
there that you cannot talk bad upon your
person it happened in another video that
we covered you know the guy that was
covering restaurants and noo single got
mad because you you cannot live a bad
review to black people you can't do that
so there's also that someone's stealing
jokes in your community sorry someone's
stealing jokes in your community is
doing a disservice to the community
you're not airing that thing out doing a
disservice it's just like the no
snitching thing it's killing everybody
out there but you can't talk because
it's going to make us loot back I
understand but you're not protecting
yourself while doing that I'm sorry what
saying no you keep going yeah that's
pretty much what I see as well on on on
that side there kind of that side thing
that I see as well that I've seen a lot
online where you cannot question your
own never yeah and you have to Forever
shut the [__] up and then you you just
live all that thing and people he said a
beautiful sentence is like
winners don't get to let losers tell a
story so there's that there's that thing
that sometimes your it be your own
people man your own Community lets you
like force you to shut up about certain
things because it's not going to look
good it feels almost like a relic of the
past of
slivery you know he not supposed to look
bad in front of the Masa it's weird
there's also that feel weird sentiment
that I feel when whenever that happens I
can't tell no you [__] up and you're
[__] me
over you're [__] up you're making me
you're stealing from us but I can't tell
you that you steal y That's a mess
anyways on this whole topic of like oh
why is he airing them out publicly
listen I don't care if Cat Williams
being loud about it I really don't care
cuz these people were being loud when
they stole from him they were stealing
from him on television wasn't that loud
when they were engaging in Theft on
National Television the loud you know
you don't like it the fact that oh
there's a little bit of conflict BR this
man committed a crime against me on
television and y'all want me to be quiet
I don't care I don't care if he AR on
everybody I don't care how messy it gets
I don't give a about none of that stuff
these people are
and a lot of people are more prot think
it's more important to protect the image
of black people rather than rooting out
evil people within the community okay
people who steal and piler they want to
make sure we look good meanwhile there's
dirty [__] happening in the back your
clean image doesn't matter you know what
I mean like it it feels like the same
thing with like the I'm not saying it's
the same level of crime with the AR
Kelly stuff or whatever but some people
don't want to critique black people so
badly that they'll let people do all
kinds of nasty [__] they're not good for
the cars either it goes It goes for our
church churches it goes for families it
goes for a lot of things yes it looks
good but you don't want to air it out
because it because you're you're fear
that it's more it won't look
good I don't really care about
protecting people who steal from others
I don't care about people who care about
protecting I don't care if you're black
white Chinese blue don't give a you get
the same treatment from me if you harm
your community if you harm your people
if you harm people in general you don't
deserve protection from nobody even if
it's my own family member I may not
attack them publicly if it's my own
family member though you're not going to
get my protection don't
care you want to go around stealing you
need to eat your consequences hold your
accountability for it you want to steal
from people you want don't don't expect
me to be jumping through hoops but y'all
here want to be more concerned with
protecting everybody even if they don't
deserve it but you're only going to do
that because you're not the one
personally affected that's fake to me
all this talk about Community but the
truth is it's because it's not your own
Pockets the truth is it's not your own
work that's being stolen cuz if it was
you you would have H to God that your
community came to your defense to stop
the person who's predating on you but no
we got to protect our own yo get Fu with
that [__] 100% what the what's the point
of the community if the moment I get
hurt they telling me to keep quiet
further victimizing myself you're not
going to get none of that support from
me never never we handle it we might not
handle it publicly but if you're not
able to handle it privately and you st
then we didn't we have nothing to talk
about you need to come out publicly and
fix what you did publicly I don't want
you to steal my [__] publicly and then
come to say sorry in private you better
get up there and say until you do then
we don't have any amends and there is no
no justice no peace none of that stuff
that's how I see it so shout out to cat
let him do his thing always been one of
the greats was still one of the greats
and uh we'll go down as one of the
greats I love his work so I support
everything he said there as long as it's
true I don't care how it comes out even
if it's a little funky also shout out to
shaneon Sharp he's killing it with the
podcast he's doing good and I like the
way that just sat back and
let he runs good sh talk your [__] he
runs good interviews I going lie but
then what oh word he was he was able to
pull back whenever when was it was the
right time to pull back and ask the
right question no no let's let's Circle
back on what you said yep yep y yep
anyways well the wife should be
submissive to uh her husband as the
husband should be submissive to
Hala look that up I don't know what
you're talking about look that up
anyways let us know what you guys think
in the comments below I have no idea
what you're talking about